welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my Watchmen episode 4 video
there were a whole bunch of crazy
moments so we'll break it all down
there's also a lot of stuff that's
happening this week so a couple
announcements at the end of the video -
we're doing a new HBO now giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about where awesome anteus is that he's
trying to escape from so careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode but top 10 and easter eggs
as we go along there were a lot of
Easter eggs and a lot of really really
crazy moments but starting with number
10 the new intro sometimes you have to
crack a few eggs to make an omelet there
were many different references to eggs
throughout the episode in a bunch of the
different storylines but I think part of
the metaphor of the cracking egg title
is also that secrets are starting to get
out like will references at the end of
the episode in three days Angela will
learn what I've been keeping from her
this big secret that I have when they
said three more days I don't know if
that means three more episodes if the
episodes will move in real time or if
that'll be the finale that they're
referring to but then there was that
person selling the organic eggs on the
roadside in Oklahoma reading the book
fog dancing if you're a big fan of the
watchman series this is actually a super
deep cut fog dancing was actually a book
that was written by someone called max
Shay who's the character that within the
world of the Watchmen series wrote the
tales of the black freighter comic book
but it also relates to all the weird
stuff that Ozymandias was doing this
week hatching in microwaving the babies
into brand-new clones to serve him
within the world of the Watchmen this
writer max Shaye who wrote that fog
dancing book also disappeared with a
bunch of other creatives and wound up on
an island owned by Ozymandias he was
using it in secret to clone a bunch of
alien squid babies to test what would
eventually be the alien squid that he
bombed New York City with so they're
using a lot of these Easter eggs in the
different storylines to tie everything
together and give you more clues about
what's really going on while this is all
going on - they play that song islands
in the stream which is also a reference
to the island that the max Shea the
writer of fog dancing was transported to
that's just a metaphor that Ozymandias
is stuck on an island so to speak but
not a literal island just a metaphorical
one because they have the transition
later in the episode that makes it seem
like he's stuck on the moon
but then number nine knock on the door
welcome lady trio one of the most
mysterious figures of the series so far
but we haven't met till this episode
she's the mysterious trillionaire we
learned this building the millenium
clock in that bought Ozymandias company
when he went into exile like he said
he's been stuck in this place for the
last four years but I believe within the
universe they've already explained that
he's been missing since 2011 or 2012 so
there's still some missing time that we
don't know where he was but number eight
she's there to buy their land for
unspecified reasons we find that
something is crashing to earth that she
knew about and that's really the reason
why she bought it because she wanted the
rights to whatever wound up landing on
that farmland so they use a lot of this
to let you know what her personality is
how she is super smart and shrewd and
she explains them how she made her
fortune the number seven was her
threatening to destroy that baby that
she created for them now if it wasn't
clear she used the egg that the woman
had tested years ago to create the baby
so really is biologically theirs but
also I think the idea that she owns all
these biomedical sciences companies is
clues to what's going on with Ozymandias
and all the clones so I definitely think
that she has something to do with where
he is and what he's doing but more on
that in a second when I talk about her
daughter because her daughter was a
really interesting character during the
episode that I think says a lot about
what's going on with Ozymandias and the
sciences that she said that she was
involved in number six after another egg
reference they pay off the opening scene
from the first episode with Angela's
great-grandparents in her learning her
true history this is where you came from
but remember she's from Vietnam just
like Lady tree oh so they haven't
explained how her parents wound up in
Vietnam and why she was born there and
not in the United States but technically
within this world Vietnam is part of the
United States so maybe her parents just
went to live there but the whole idea is
that she's tied in a much more
significant way to the 1921 incident
it's very meaningful for her but she
still hates will right now despite the
fact that she seems like she's caught up
in something way bigger than she totally
understands that has something to do
with the Millennium clock Lori laughs
about the car crashing down and they
sort of sink the episode up with the end
of last week's episode no that's my car
just totally fell out of the sky it was
weird that she didn't totally believe
Lori right away you think her mind would
be a little bit more open but they sort
of pay that off later
when lady trio secretly communicates
with her about her grandfather he's
asking about his pills tell him to go
screw himself my number 5 was that
weird breakfast conversation that they
had about the chief not going to heaven
because heaven supposedly doesn't exist
no I'm not a religious person so I don't
really mind if they're atheists or
anything like that I just thought it was
weird in an episode that he would say
that so directly to little kids oh
there's no heaven he just went to
nothingness normally you don't see
people do that with children in TV shows
unless it's a really religious TV show
which this is not but maybe he's just an
atheist and that's why he was having
that conversation with them but number 4
time for the reckoning
so Angela finally comes clean to
lookingglass about the Chiefs secret
history gives him his Klan robes and
they're also going to analyze what's in
Wills pills apparently they're really
important there probably was helping
keeping him alive past the age of 100
like there were all the references in
the earlier episodes about how he's this
super old man there's no way he could
have ended the chief because he's in a
wheelchair yet somehow it seems kind of
like he did at least all the evidence
points to him doing it number three was
Lube man this was just hilarious like
what was he doing there by was he spying
on her is he connected to lady trio or
is he connected to the Calvary or is he
just a regular vigilante and it's a who
watches the Watchmen situation like it's
a joke about who watches the people that
are watching us because angela is
watching us all the time there was also
another weird moment between her and
Senator Kean when he came back he was
acting kind of like an asshole and it
only hammers home my belief that he had
something to do with setting up what
happened at the funeral like maybe this
was all part of some agenda that he has
that Angela and Lorie sort of sidelined
and he's kind of pissed off at her about
that Laurie gives us a whole bunch more
details about will he was a cop in New
York City in the 40s and 50s then
retired early
she also connects the dots between the
wheelchair tire marks at Crawford's
crime scene and will being over a
hundred years old he'd be in a
wheelchair like she totally knows what's
going on and just hasn't said out loud
yet number two was the scene of them
explaining Laurie's backstory in the car
the Doctor Manhattan references and then
the Millennium Clock explainer from Lady
trio's daughter is a thermodynamic
miracle my ex used to talk about him all
the time it's all connected man I loved
how she kind of poked fun at Angela
wearing a mask oh I used to dress up and
fight crime to know I wear a mad
to hide yes to hide from the pain and if
it wasn't clear PD in the back seat is
the PD from PD pedia on HBO's website
that has all those extra files and
details and bonus material for the
episodes if you've seen the Watchmen
movie or you read the original comic
series you already know her so expect
her back story and how she found out
about the comedian being her father
based on the way she acted in last
week's episode and all the references
they made it seems like she's kind of
moved past that she's using his last
name now - Laurie Blake Blake is the
last name of the comedian lady trio's
daughter also explains the purpose of
the millenium clock and why it's located
in Oklahoma of all places like why here
when you're a trillionaire you could
build it anywhere you want she claims
that it's just meant to be a clock but
you know Doomsday Clock references what
is the clock actually counting down to
what's gonna happen in three days but
the reason why of all places in the
world they built it in Oklahoma is
because it's the safest place on planet
earth safest from nuclear attacks safe
lives from any kind of natural disaster
so if you thought it was weird that they
would set the TV show in and around
Tulsa Oklahoma
that explains why but they obviously
haven't revealed a true purpose of the
clock yet love the joke about Ozymandias
statue why did you make him look old he
looks like crap
oh we Revere our elders in Vietnam where
I come from well here it just looks like
crap I also think they laid a lot of
clues about what's going on with Lady
trio's daughter during a lot of these
conversations too but number one
probably the biggest thing was
Ozymandias using crab traps to fish for
the baby clones that were growing in
that pond it looked kind of like a pond
but because it's at night it's kind of
hard to tell he sticks them in a special
machine that grows them to full
adulthood in moments kind of like
microwaving a pizza then they sort of
used the next couple of moments to
explain where all the clones come from
and what he's doing with them in
revealed that he's destroyed all the
other clones sorry for the mess I had a
rough night then uses the dead ones to
test the giant catapult just reiterating
the idea that he's within this special
closed environment that someone's
created to keep him in a prison so to
speak when they zoom out on the spyglass
in transition to Earth's moon I think
that's them implying that he's on the
moon not on Mars like I thought in last
week's episode but I did believe just
because the way they came back frozen
that they were getting fired
into orbit out of the atmosphere and
that's why they were freezing so I feel
like that's them confirming that but it
still doesn't explain what deal he made
with lady trio because now I think that
she's secretly connected to all those
weird baby clones and him being stuck on
the moon I'm really starting to like the
theory that Thomas on the clone that
he's playing is actually meant to be a
clone of real Doctor Manhattan like you
have all these Doctor Manhattan clones that
he's disposing of all over the place
let's go fish another Manhattan baby out
of the crab traps but he's very careful
to reiterate that he's not responsible
for creating these clones someone else
is and then at the end of the episode
when Lady trio's daughter wakes up and
tells the story about the nightmare that
she had which sounds like one of Lady
trio's memories from her childhood in
Vietnam like she's reliving real
memories that lady trio or one of her
ancestors had when she said that she
Revere's her elders I think the idea is
is that her daughter is secretly a clone
either of her lady trio or maybe her
mother or her grandmother and that's why
she's having those memories it's like
genetic memory that you passed down but
everyone let me know in the comments
what is your theory about what's going
on with the clock and what lady trio in
a wills plan secretly is this going to
culminate in the next three days there's
so much big stuff happening this week to
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 1 is
airing tonight I'll do a video for that
it'll post Monday morning Disney Plus is
also launching on Tuesday in the
mandalorian episode one will be dropping
then I'll do a video for that too so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos
when I post them while you wait for
everything click here for my watchmen
episode 3 video and click here for that
brand new rick and morty season 4
opening scene thank you so much for
watching everybody's day it awesome i'll
see you guys tonight!